stade gilbert gensac de trappes les
joueurs locaux sont concentrés dans le
tunnel avant d'entrer sur la pelouse les
trappistes savent qu'en cas de victoire
contre ouvert janvier il faudra un grand
pas vers la montée en régionale 2 une
fois l'engagement donné les trappistes
tente de prendre l'ascendant massy light
moss en arrive à marquer sur ce corner
et aux coups font ensuite le break juste
avant la mi temps par car à quoi tu as 2
à 0 une première mi temps maîtrisée dans
l'ensemble pour mène au score 2 à 0
maintenant voilà une deuxième période
contre une équipe qui joue le maintien
il va falloir plié le match en mettant
un troisième but et surtout pas les
laisser espérer
au retour des vestiaires 3 pouces pour
se mettre à l'abri mais n'arrive pas à
conclure malgré plusieurs situations
dangereuses dans cette deuxième période
score final 2 à 0 on en parle c'est de
jouer au contraire on a attaqué
malheureusement on n'a pas su
concrétiser les occasions mais bon là
aujourd'hui on va retenir la victoire
après cette victoire trappe occupe
désormais la première place du
classement à deux journées de la fin du
championnat
c'est le sprint final de match c'est pas
le moment de baisser les bras surtout
quoi donc on va mobiliser nos forces
rester concentré essayer de finir au
mieux car avec deux victoires on monte
donc là on va essayer de finir
correctement
prochain match pour les trappistes le
dimanche 19 mai sur le terrain de rueil
malmaison mais en attendant les joueurs
peuvent savourer
[Applaudissements]